la question qui nous est posée est
simple ce soir est-ce que vous oui ou
non gardez un système de retraite par
répartition
et bien chaque partie du gouvernement
c'est et on l'a vu en 95 dans la vie en
2003 l'avion 2010 on l'a vu en 2015 que
nous sommes face à des défis qu'il faut
relever d'abord le défi démographique
chacun sait qu'il ne reste plus que 1,7
cotisants pour un retraité il sera de
1,5 dans quelques années
et oui oui la politique nathaliste les
socialistes se souviennent de la fin de
l'universalité des allocations
familiales d'abord des raisons
financières ensuite puisque
malheureusement nos retraites un peu
plus de 340 milliards ne sont payés que
par 80% de cotisations sociales ce qui
veut dire qui a un déficit structurel
depuis de 30 milliards d'euros le corps
d'abord l'a très bien dit et je vous
rappelle une chose c'est que déjà l'état
vient en compensation alors il n'y a pas
36 solutions soit dit mais c'est les
retraites nous ne le voulons pas ça
n'augmenter les impôts nous ne le
voulons pas et je me souviens de la
réforme Touraine qui était cité en
exemple qui cette année est allé
chercher 2,3 milliards d'euros dans les
poches des salariés de la France et puis
des raisons de justice sociale on ne
peut pas à tout moment dire qu'il y a
des petites retraites et ne pas apporter
de solution on ne peut pas dire à tout
moment qu'il y a des carrières hachées
avec une injustice terrible
c'est injustice terrible c'est que les
personnes qui ont des carrières hachées
n'ont un taux plein qu'à 67 ans et j'ai
pas entendu sur ces bancs des hommes et
les fans capables de les défendre alors
que ce sont majoritairement des femmes
et puis il y a les régimes spéciaux sur
lesquels il faut avoir le courage de
dire que certaines tâches qui étaient
très pénibles sur moins de Venus et
qu'il faut bouger sur des régimes
spéciaux alors les démocrates que nous
sommes avec comme je dirais Jean-Paul
Mathilde sérénité active juge
indispensable courageux de porter un
certain nombre de mesures de justice
sociale d'abord une première mesure mes
chers collègues qui est la clause de
revoyure j'ai entendu Olivier du soft et
dire tout à l'heure la première ministre
la vie ce week-end qu'elle était
favorable et une clause de revoyure
c'est quoi une clause de revoyure et
bien c'est pas donné un blanc simple
pour 10 ou 15 ans sur une réforme sans
mesurer les effets c'est très fort on ne
peut pas comme cela de façon aveugle
imaginez que l'on a conçu un système et
après ne si réellement les mesures que
nous avons opéré sont efficaces cette
cloche de revoyure elle sera impartiale
et sur un sujet de la Cour des comptes
elle sera sous l'égide du corps les
parlements sera à nouveau réunis et le
permettra au gouvernement de faire en
sorte de tirer les leçons naturellement
de cette réforme c'est clause de
réveilla c'est un acte de transparence
un œil de confiance pour nous
concitoyens et en particulier la
jeunesse il ne croit pas une seconde à
la réforme des retraites ensuite les
carrières arrachées vous avez messieurs
les ministres avancés sur un sujet
majeur 70% des carrières hachées sont
celles des femmes qui attendent 67 ans
pour avoir un taux plein vous avez
avancé sur les aidants vous avez avancé
sur les congés parentaux nous vous
demandons Monsieur le Ministre
d'entendre que pour les femmes pour les
trimestres liées à la maternité on
puisse aller plus loin car elles sont
encore pénalisés alors chacun a bien
compris que le débat devant lequel nous
sommes est un débat à moitié tronqué on
a échappé tout à l'heure à la motion
référendaire circulez il n'y a rien à
voir on a échappé à la motion du rejet
la motion du rejet c'est vous inquiétez
pas dans six mois dans un an on le
giflera mais les urgences les urgences
mes chers collègues elles sont là elles
sont sur la table on ne peut pas parler
de petites retraite sans régler le
problème maintenant on ne peut pas
parler de carrière hachée sans régler le
parler des seniors comme cela en
laissant deux seniors sur trois sur le
bord de la route quel gâchis humain
quelle absence de transmission de savoir
aux jeunes c'est dramatique de laisser
cela ne que n'avez-vous fait lorsque
vous étiez au pouvoir il fallait y aller
chez Jérôme Guedj il fallait le faire il
fallait le faire avec courage et le
faire avec détermination alors mes chers
collègues moi j'ai un regret
j'ai un regret parce que
de façon assidue en commission on a eu
des beaux débats entre l'article 1 et
l'article 3 mais vous avez créé
vous-même les conditions du nom des bas
avec 20 000 amendements et vous savez
d'ores et déjà on va le dire aux
Français que vos amendements ne seront
pas étudiés et vous prenez en otage
l'ensemble de l'Assemblée car nous
n'irons pas debout et c'est vous qui
avez voulu c'est votre responsabilité
vous devrez vous devrez rendre des
comptes devant les Français et je
terminerai en vous disant arrêtez de
nous parler des 64 ans on y arrivera pas
à cause de vous
je vous remercie mon cher collègue